Joe's baby chicks are name another thing
as cute and adorable as them name one
I'll wait a puppy isn't even cute as
cute as it when a chick is born when a
chick is born that big and they just
like they're all like the hair looks
like they touch a light socket and then
just like looking around all frag and
stuff I would say the only thing as cute
as maybe a baby chick are are are Asian
babies yeah Asian babies the number one
baby the number one cutest baby I
understand why people adopt them left
right I understand I I I would love the
opportunity to have an Asian baby
couldn't agree more I I say I throw in
black and Asians okay black babies and
Asian babies you know what's tough as a
parent you won't know if they're ugly
till later cuz they all come out great
yeah I never seen I've never seen an
ugly black baby I've never seen an ugly
Asian baby but I see ugly Asian and
black adults but and which is
interesting what happens